we're going to uh
to see the unveiling of the pole
the pole marker
it's uh it's a ceremony so i dressed up
and uh
it's a south pole tradition once a year
unveiling of the marker that was
designed the previous year
by the winter overs
so let's go
is
the story is this is january 1st
and uh
every year
we have to mark the new location of the
excessive rotation because we are on
this
large sheet of ice
that moves by about 10 meters a year
so
that's what we're doing today
so this is the old marker that's the old
one yeah
it's
old and dirty and it's time for change
time for a change enough of this one
and i guess
the new one
is
around here
about to be unveiled so once a year the
pole marker is actually over the
geographic pool the rest of time
that's last year's pole marker
that is this year's full marker so
nobody's seen it since they've presented
it to me it's been in my drawer
so as you also might have seen in the
front of the station there's a display
case
where uh the pool markers are actually
small enough to fit in
go um after they spent their year at the
pool we'll leave that other one out here
for a little while longer
yeah it's like it looks like jupiter
because of the vans
but
yeah
saturn rings i don't really understand
either
but maybe it's not to be understood oh
it's nice
i actually it's saturn but it looks like
jupiter yeah because there's bands so
i'm not quite sure wait it's supposed to
be silent
so as of today
the earth is actually turning
around this point
hi everyone
uh what was i gonna say
yeah i look a little tired because
i just came back from work and it's 3am
can't you see the sun is over there that
means it's 3am
i just came here
before going to sleep
to
just show you this is the ceremonial
poll right here this is a place that
actually doesn't change where we have
this nice aluminized or metalized
globe and then you see the
flags of the countries
who i think have signed the entire
treaty i'm not quite sure